bueno muchas gracias por esta
oportunidad
esta es una ratificación de la decisión
de inadmisión de una impugnación ante el
tribunal supremo de londres por lo tanto
esta es una formalización de forma
exclusiva de parte de esta corte de gran
bretaña hacia el ámbito interior
principal sin embargo como ustedes mismo
ha manifestado todavía existen
pendientes recursos y alegaciones que se
debe hacer a este instante a esta
instancia de carácter político y ustedes
han podido hablar ya con julian assange
cómo se encuentra y cómo tomó esta
decisión
bueno llegué no se desconocía desde el
14 de marzo cuando precisamente fue
negada la posibilidad de recurrir ante
el tribunal supremo por un elemento
jurídico no relevante el conoce de esta
situación se entenderá la afectación que
se tiene no solamente en la actualidad
sino de años atrás por las situaciones
psicológicas y físicas que está
atravesando en sobre todo en el
encarcelamiento en ver más por lo tanto
si se encuentra en una tensión muy
complicada ninguna situación psicológica
que igualmente la jueza vanessa varias
ere detención por lo tanto en los
recursos se van agotado 20.000 tiempo y
como ya hemos dicho ahora es la ministra
patel quien debe decidir sobre esta
extradición en un plazo de dos meses que
posibles escenarios se abren a partir de
ahora y en caso de que para tel apruebe
la extradición que recursos tendrían
para evitarla
tenemos hasta el 18 de mayo para
presentar los argumentos donde la micro
interior británica si es que obviamente
esta situación no cambiaría el rumbo de
la orden nuestra visión todavía existen
recursos pendientes hay un recurso de
cros appeal que también se debe
manifestar está pendiente y posterior a
eso ya había casi una decisión final que
se podría también recurrir a un
organismo europeo de derechos humanos
pero eso sería una última posibilidad